okay I have potentially really good or
sad news for you we are dangerously
close dangerously close to hitting the
2,100 patron goal for releasing our 12
to 15 part critical thinking miniseries
I've been talking about it every day
because we are so close to this thing we
fundraise doing membership and on
patreon patreon is a platform at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
where anyone can make a contribution of
as little as $1 a month and there's no
maximum contribution you can make you go
to patreon.com/scishow you hit the
orange button that says become a patron
done deal we have goals on our patreon
page and one goal that we have
established is that when we reach 2,100
patrons we will produce for you a
multi-part critical-thinking miniseries
it will first be released to patrons it
will eventually be released to everybody
so it's not just for patrons the patrons
get the early reward because they
trigger for lack of a better term the
release of the miniseries but then we
make it available to everybody we have
already talked about how we have a
completed animated introduction for the
patreon critical thinking miniseries it
looks great we've already sampled one of
the 12 to 15 parts that the miniseries
will contain and the goal is 2,100
patrons last week I told you hey were
under 100 patrons to go earlier this
week late last week rather we had only
85 patrons left to go Monday we had 57
to go
yesterday it was 43 and the target now
is only 18 patrons away and we basically
have until midnight tonight now you
might be saying well hold on David why
why did it midnight tonight what if you
hit the goal tomorrow or the next day on
the first of the month patreon attempt
to collect everybody's pledges and when
that happens sadly there are people
whose credit cards will have expired
from January it's usually three to five
percent of the patrons
and when that happens on the first of
the month our patron number goes down
it's really depressing when it happens
but it does and there's nothing we can
do about it knowing that at midnight
tonight that is going to take place my
desire would be let's get to the 2100
today we're only 18 patrons away and
let's just be done with it and move on
with the critical thinking miniseries
yeah I'm on pins and needles here it's
like a Patriots Super Bowl comeback or
that night of the Iowa caucuses where
Bernie Sanders nearly won you're
catching up but we got a deadline coming
up it's kind of like that although maybe
those aren't the exact analogies I would
make but those those are certainly
interesting and politically relevant I
would say yeah so so let's do it tonight
18 patrons to go even a dollar gets us
closer patreon.com slash david pakman
show let's do this thing and move on to
the production and release of this
miniseries